we're told that the total cost of
filling up your car with gas varies
directly
varies directly with the number of
gallons of gasoline you are purchasing
so this first statement tells us that if
x is equal to the number of gallons
number of gallons
gallons purchased
and y
is equal to the cost
of
filling up the car
filling
car this first statement tells us that y
varies directly with the number of
gallons with x so that means that y
is equal to some constant some constant
we'll just call that k
times x this is what it means to vary
directly if x goes up y will go up we
don't know what the rate is k tells us
the rate if x goes down y will be down
now they give us more information and
this will help us figure out what k is
if a gallon of gas if a gallon of gas
cost 225 how many gallons could you
purchase for 18 dollars so if x is equal
to one this this statement up here a
gallon of gas that tells us if we get
one gallon if x is equal to one
then y is 225 right y is what it costs
they tell us one gallon costs 225. so
you could write it right here 225
is equal to k
times x times 1
times 1. well i didn't have to write
that times 1 there it's essentially
telling us exactly what the rate is what
k is we don't even have to write that
one there k is equal to 2.25
that's what this told us right there so
the equation how y varies with x is
y
is equal to 2.25
x where x is the number of gallons we
purchase
y is the cost of that purchase so it's
225 a gallon and then they ask us how
many gallons
how many gallons could you purchase for
18
so 18 is going to be our total cost it
is y cost of filling the car
so 18 is going to be equal to 2.25
x
now if we want to
solve for x we can divide both sides by
2.25
so let's do that
you divide 18 by 2.25 divide 2.25 x by
2.25
and what do we get let me scroll down a
little bit
the right hand side the 2.25 cancel out
you get x
and then what is 18 divided by
2.25 so let me write this down so first
of all i'd just like to think of it as a
fraction 2.25
is the same thing let me write it over
here
2.25
is equal to 2 and 1 4 which is the same
thing as 9 over 4 so 18 divided by 18
divided by 2.25 is equal to 18 divided
by 9 over 4 which is equal to 18
times 4 over 9 or 18 over 1 times 4 over
9 and let's see 18 divided by 9
18 divided by 9 is 2 9 divided by 9 is 1
that simplifies pretty nicely into 8. so
18 divided by 2.25 is eight so we can
buy eight gallons
for eighteen dollars